so Joel and
I we are not related but I feel like we
are because our history is this so my
best one of my very best and closest
friends in this world was this girl who
was a junior model um she was 16 I was
14 we met in a coffee house and we have
been lifelong sisters but her name is
Cameron Diaz just
yeah and so she is married to your twin
brother Ben my twin brother benj Uncle
Ben Uncle benj Benji Madden yeah and so
you guys are this whole family now your
wife Nicole who is the most
extraordinary woman yeah I got to know
her through Cameron and I was like oh
this is the coolest woman ever she's
cool yeah she's cool I mean she really
is like the cat's pajamas Why is she's
so cool Joel I think Nicole is a
real the more you know her the more you
love her it takes time to get to know
her right but she's just classy she was
you know Lionel and Brenda did a good
job they they raised someone with a lot
of integrity and a lot of
class you know Lionel comes on this
show he uh he gives me some grief about
how all of us made him almost lose his
hair growing up you know with all of us
girls being you know girls who had to
figure their way out and I'm like but
aren't you proud now like we all turned
out good rights turned out better than
good you all turned out I mean you're
some of the most amazing I have a lot of
respect for women uh who have had to
work in a really tough industry for
women to work in that ha that all of you
just are are really strong amazing
powerful women and and I uh I think
we're better men because we're around
all of you uh but I've watched Nicole
navigate for 17 years now we've been
together and I've watched 17 years yeah
it's crazy it's
crazy don't ask me
how actually I want to ask you how how
do you you know I've been around you you
have two beautiful children yeah we our
kids are great you have a a beautiful
life together we got lucky with our kids
they're they're easy I always tell my
kids you make it so easy be a dad just
they're just good kids they really are
they're they're great and I think
they're like their mom I don't think we
pretend to be perfect either I think
we're all human that's why I love your
tattoo I was lucky to meet uh to have my
brother and then to meet cam they have a
beautiful relationship they do to have
this like growing family of good people
that all are also all imperfect and not
trying to like present like we have it
all figured out but we work on ourselves
and you guys all work on yourselves like
I you know I know each therapy yeah I
know each one of you together and
individually lot of therapy you go to
you know you work you do the work
[Music]
yeah